after the fall of the Soviet Union and
even China's migration to a market-based
economy even though they saw call
themselves communist their economy is
now essentially capitalist there's been
a kind of a general consensus around the
world that capitalism is the way to go
and I you know just to put my bias out
there right from the get-go I am in that
camp I would consider myself I would
consider myself a capitalist but what I
want to do in this video is do a little
bit more of a nuanced discussion of
capitalism versus say socialism because
I feel like there has been especially
here in the United States and in the
West there's sometimes a knee-jerk
reaction against anything that even has
a whiff of the government getting
involved or even a whiff of of socialism
so I want to think more about what are
we trying to achieve with a capitalist
system and where we could fall into kind
of the things we don't want to achieve
if some of the aspects of capitalism are
allowed to go on without any type of
without any type of controls or maybe
some type of regulation I don't want to
advocate anything I just want to give a
maybe a framework for thinking about it
so you ask any capitalist including
myself you say well what's good about
capitalism and you and I would say well
you know it's it aligns everyone's
incentives so it's good good incentives
if you work harder you can earn more you
can generate a capital for yourself you
can use that to improve your standard of
living you can reinvest that capital so
it's good it's a good incentive
structure I'm not saying that everyone
is motivated purely by the desire to
earn I think you know there's plenty of
people in the world who are motivated
for the desire for social good for
elevating mankind but the general sense
is in a lot of parts of and is that
those type of things are specific to
certain domains but in other domains if
someone's running a trucking company
it's not clear that someone would run a
trucking company optimally just for the
good of mankind maybe they would run
some type of nonprofit that way but a
trucking company or a a farm or
something like that who knows so in
general you have a good incentive
structure there's also this notion in a
capitalist
me that it's a meritocracy it is
meritocracy and I'm going to I'm going
to actually put a box around this
because the meritocracy in my mind is
super duper important because even if
you talk to us almost everyone is a fan
of a meritocracy even the Communists
were fan of a meritocracy they would
give exams to people and have the the
people who are successful have more
authority within within the communist
regime so meritocracy is something that
other that everyone lays claim to and
actually a lot of socialists or
communists would claim that extreme
forms of capitalism when the wealth
disparity becomes too extreme or where
you have inherited wealth is actually
goes against the idea of meritocracy so
let me actually put let me put
meritocracy here meritocracy here is
well and we'll talk about that in a
second and then the other idea is is
that you know you have you have
innovation you have innovation in
capitalism and these are all related
these are all related ideas that if the
incentives are good if if capital gets
in the hands of people who are most
deserving of it because they've somehow
earned it they somehow innovated that
can also lead to innovation because the
right people are are handling the
capital now if we go to the social the
socialist side of things they'll say
well look there's there's a social
cohesiveness to this so let me write
this down and I won't speak to the soul
you know I I don't claim what I'm going
to do in this video is comprehensive of
all of the pros and cons of either I
just want to give a little bit of nuance
to the discussion to the discussion so
social cohesiveness you don't you won't
have this situation where you have you
know gazillionaire sitting behind a
walled compound with armed guards and
there are people right on the other side
of that wall compound starving to death
who and you know these people don't even
necessarily view themselves as part of
the same society as part of the you know
that they it's somehow a responsibility
to reach each other and that is
happening in some parts of the world
where you have severe disparities and
wealth though the rich people don't even
kind of view themselves as you know the
same species as the poor people or even
vice versa you have the other idea of
kind of you know and I'll put this in in
in quotes of fairness fairness and I'll
put it in quotes
because one could say well it's fair to
if you if you make more if you work
harder you should get more if you
innovate more you should get more and
then their notion of fairness as well
yeah but look you know sometimes this
wealth gets so extreme sometimes you
have this notion of inherited wealth
generation after generation old money
what's fair about that that people are
just randomly born into a situation
where they can just extract the interest
off of their wealth and never have to
work and other people have to work super
hard and they really get nothing for it
so you know this notion of fairness I'll
put it over here as well fairness
because there's arguments for either and
so like I said I am definitely biased to
the capitalist side of things I think
there is an important to these things
that we have on the right-hand side but
the reality at least you know what we've
seen in the economic experiments of the
20th century is that even though
communists and socialists might speak
might speak to these type of things to a
large degree it becomes even it it
becomes there's less so he shal social
cohesiveness the the senior communists
in the soviet union's would drive
fancier cars and they did have a very
different lifestyle than the workers and
they would hide that lifestyle and then
you would you know it would lead to a
lot of hypocrisy in general the extreme
forms of socialism not clear that it was
a meritocracy we might have been just
the best people climbing up the the
party ladder that get to the top as
opposed to the people who would innovate
and actually produce in a better way but
with that said I want to give fair
warning I want to give fair warning that
capitalism if it's kind of goes
unchecked in certain ways it can also
lead to those same problems of socialism
in the main the main problems there when
you think about good incentives I think
the incentives and once again I'm giving
my opinion here the incentives work out
of what well when you have a bunch of
competitors who can compete and innovate
and it makes complete sense that let's
say that this person comes up with an
innovation and because they have that
innovation they're able to provide a
better good that's cheaper to society
and so they make more profits and it
seems reasonable that that person should
get more profits and more wealth and
grow and it could even be good
for society because this person is an
innovator maybe there was an element of
luck there but it seems like they're
competent at managing these resources so
it's good for society to give them more
resources to manage the problem we're
capitalism where the areas were get
where it becomes less clear that
capitalism is unambiguously good is a
situation where this person becomes
outright dominant so let's say that this
person becomes so big that all of that
none of these other players can even
compete with them so they all disappear
this person can just undercut everybody
and all of the other players disappear
and this is a situation of a monopoly
and the problem here monopoly and it
problem is when this guy had competition
he had every incentive to work harder he
had every incentive to innovate it was a
meritocracy because the person who
innovates well grows the fastest but
once you get to a monopoly stage and
everyone else has died down this is the
only player in in the economy then all
of a sudden he has no incentive to
innovate this this corporation or this
person can just keep raising prices
there's no competition there's no one
else to say hey I can have a better
product I can sell it to you cheaper and
so it actually goes against the ideas of
innovation that's why it's really
important and that's why it's part of
especially in the United States it's
part of the the economic system that you
that you try to break up monopolies that
you don't like monopolistic practices
the other risk that you have when you
start having a lot of wealth and a lot
of influence in a kind of one entity or
one person or one corporation and this
can sometimes happen well it can happen
in a democratic or even a non-democratic
regime is that the control of resources
aren't just control of those resources
aren't just control of land and
buildings and railroads they can also
use it to influence government influence
influence government and in the United
States this has kind of been instantly
institutionalized in the form of
lobbying and when you have excess
resources and you can influence
government in this way you can get the
government so let's say this is the
government over here you can get the
government to essentially do things for
you so it works to your advantage and
maybe allowing you eventually to become
a monopoly so you
kind of view this is crony capitalism
where you're you know lobbying can be of
a form of legalized bribery and in that
way you kind of own the elected
officials I'm not saying that this is
happening everywhere but it could happen
and in that situation you have the
government acting on behalf of these and
once again it goes against the idea of a
meritocracy because when you have this
cycle developing maybe this person right
over here has the innovation but this
person doesn't have the clout doesn't
have the influence with the government
and so this guy gets the government
contract for the planes or this guy gets
the the the tax benefits from the
government so that he can be even more
competitive he can he can undercut this
guy even though this guy has the
innovation the other element and I could
talk about this for hours and these are
just things to think about are the idea
of inherited wealth and I'm not saying
that inherited wealth is a is a bad
thing but there's this idea that let's
say someone through their competence
maybe competence with a little bit of
luck is able to accrue a huge amount of
wealth then maybe they're not even a
monopolist but they're able to get a
huge amount of wealth but they were able
to do it they were able to do it
that they're really good managers
they're kind of these you know really
smart dude he can he can really manage a
lot of resources well the question
arises is what happens when this person
passes away in a very purely capitalist
situation you pass this on you pass this
on to your children so you pass this on
to your children and the issue here is
one what did this person do to earn it
and also from a society's point of view
maybe this person here is a dummy maybe
you know maybe there was another kid
maybe there's another kid over here who
was born at the exact same time who is
way you know way smarter and who you
know but this this kid is now in control
of a hundred gazillion dollars and he
can completely miss manage the resources
so that they're they're completely
wasted and so you have this idea of over
time inherited wealth in a capitalist
society can go against the ideas of
meritocracy it can go against the idea
of good incentives because if this guy
inherits enough money has no incentive
to work why should he you know have to
study hard and go in
you know the tackle math and all of that
he's inherited enough money that he can
he gets millions of dollars just off of
the interest and you know why should he
educate himself you got he got daddy's
or granddad's money and so it also goes
against the idea and why should he try
to innovate why should he ever do
anything I'll just he could maybe just
hire some of these people and give them
you know kind of a minimum salary
whatever it takes and so it kind of goes
against these ideas of fairness and all
of that and I'm not saying that I'm
against inheritance
I'm just saying it's something to think
about and there's some probably
threshold of inheritance that it starts
to undermine some of these these ideas
of a meritocracy and good incentives and
fairness and all of that and that's why
I think it's funny when people who call
themselves old money old money are kind
of proud of it
that they view themselves as somehow
being part of a better caste because old
money means that you did not earn the
money yourself that you're a granddad or
your great granddad earned the money and
you've just happened to be born in this
family and you know are essentially just
living off of the interest and it's
funny because they'll talk about new
money new money is that some type of you
know they're not as good as old money
but at least the new money people maybe
it was through luck but maybe it was
through competence or innovation this is
something that at least in my mind I'd
respect more than old old money you've
done nothing you're I mean what's the
difference between old money or a king
and a queen or the aristocracy of Europe
that kind of goes against a lot of the
philosophy philosophical underpinnings
of what the United States is even based
on so I'll leave you there I just wanted
to add a little bit of nuance to the
conversation I will say I'll say it
again you know I come to this
conversation with a capitalist bias but
I I'm hoping that this gives you a
little bit of more nuance so that
instead of saying capitalism is an
unambiguous good and socialism isn't
unambiguous bad these are the things
that are unappreciated so that we can
have a meritocracy if everyone is
educated then you have a kind of a level
playing field you have this notion of
equal opportunity and that does involve
some type of re you know on some scale
redistribution of at least in the form
of education maybe you do need some form
of you know way for people to get health
care you don't want people dying in this
I'm not going to take a stance here but
I'm just showing you this you can't just
even though I do consider myself a
capitalism you can't just say that
everything has to be purely capitalist
and you can't have any any notion of
government intervention you maybe want
the government to enter to invest in
things like long term research where
they don't have an immediate profit
motive but 50 20 100 years down the
future it might allow the society to
thrive or whatever else so I'll leave
you leave you there